hey chums uh you may have noticed this
episode is much shorter than usual
that will be explained in the episode
but uh don't worry it's not anything sad
we're not divorcing
uh but uh you will not get distracted by
our beautiful faces you'll be able to
focus entirely
on our gorgeous dulcet tones dulcet
tones
is a great phrase i love it i'm going to
use it more you should too enjoy the
show
[Music]
hello and welcome to she doesn't read
the news with me chris
turner and me as win and this week we
are in
the big apple we're in new york and we
i i don't think you've read the news
this week have you uh i haven't no but
interestingly coinciding with our
decision to do a much shorter episode
there has been no news this week
well isn't that convenient i know um so
yes you may have gathered from that and
seeing the length of this in your
podcast app or on youtube that it is a
very brief episode i don't but is it an
episode i think this is just us telling
everyone we're not really doing an
episode
it's it's a placeholder i think yeah
we're just informing you that um we're
in new york
and we've been very busy with the shows
it's been delightful that makes it
sounds like i'm doing shows
well alice oh you don't want to talk
about your secret career as a clown
ah no no the clown thing is for me
although um i wanted to bring this up
um clara who was on the show with me
with us
with you all right calm down this secret
little just you podcast clara and i
have been talking recently about how
there's a really specific
annoying thing which is
like really commonly used
quirky things so for instance people who
are like
i don't i know this is like so weird
because most people really like clowns
but i think
i think clowns are creepy clowns are
freaky i just don't like them
i think it's their shoes i know i'm wild
right it's that uh another one is um
people who say they don't like the word
moist
like i get that the first person who
said i don't like the word moist was
like very witty
but at this point we get it no one likes
the word moist it's just an icky worm
it can't be your personality that you
don't like the word moist
also it's by far not the worst word the
worst word
categorically is grotty no i love the
word grotty i hate the word grotty
it's because when i was a child i think
my first memory of being a child was
having my nappy changed or diaper
and someone going have you got a grotty
body
that's hot that is oh no alice don't be
into adult diapers
yeah no that's i'm i'm turned on now um
yeah so we need to come up with a word
for this a word for
like trying to be quirky but misjudging
and actually being basic
listeners if you have any suggestions
for such a word please do
write in to the uh the mail bag with
berkey berkey you back quasic
quasic oh i like that that sounds like a
programming language
yeah i'm not sure it's quite right
anyway um but yeah no we haven't we have
not done
any reading of the news i've been doing
lots of shows it was very
weird to be back on stage yeah i had had
410 days between
my live gigs and i told the audience
that and they applauded which was very
nice
american audiences will applaud anything
i mean they applauded me saying i'm from
the uk
and they applauded me the other night
when i took off my jacket
actually clarify i was wearing a shirt
underneath the jacket and i said to them
i'm just warm yeah yeah they're very
they're very um clap happy you know yeah
but i like that don't stop these are
live shows in new york
by the time you're listening to this uh
if you're listening to this on the day
we put it out there are a couple more
shows at the comedy cellar but don't
worry because i'll be in new york much
more frequently
in the coming months you'll be able to
see me there new york's been
quite nice hasn't it we've seen some
really interesting things
yeah it's uh you know it's a good good
place i have not yet seen a rat
so i saw my first rat today and it was a
rare rat
it was missing a tail oh a poor thing so
it could have just been
a beaver who was missing a tail yeah
what what
animals don't have tails quite a few
macs cats
but um but rats are they're
sort of unique you can tell a ranch they
haven't they have a sort of
aura yeah it had about a half inch stump
on the back
poor little thing i know but you know i
like to think that he had shed his tail
as an act of self too could have been a
lady rat
could have been a lady i i never think
of rats as family unless they have long
eyelashes
i never think of animals as feminine
unless they have long eyelashes although
everyone thinks colonel within
is a girl but that's because he's
beautiful and women are beautiful that
is very true
um animal chat in new york this seems to
be an epidemic of its own
people with very small dogs walking
their dogs by carrying them i saw two
again tonight
it's everywhere right these are dogs
that i guess cannot walk more than 10
minutes but
a 10 minute walk isn't really a war
what's funny is that you know how in
like the early 2000s there was a fad
right like paris hilton would have a
tiny dog in a bag didn't she have that
like what what it was
a kuchaku or something but she also had
like a pet
like i don't know it was like this weird
animal that's legal in new york
chinchilla no no i promise you it's like
a weird
wrapped bat i'm skeptical that you know
more about paris hilton than i do i'm
gonna look this up
okay i'm wrong paris hilton does indeed
or did indeed have a pet
how do you say that word kinkajou which
is different to a
sexually adventurous yiddish man
um paris hilton what a fascinating
dissertation she will make
because look in this picture here she's
clutching her kinkajou baby love
and a chinchilla and they look very
similar that's not a chinchilla dying
that's a chihuahua a chihuahua sorry
yes i think someone convinced her that
she bought two chihuahuas
the point is that um the people carrying
their dogs in new york city in 2021 it's
not the same paris hilton vibe
it is not a oh yes i'm very glamorous
and i have a small dog
it's a my dog is exhausted i am
exhausted
this is like a i mean it looks like
they're like emigrating
you know during a revolution it's
they've gathered up all their things and
left the houses because of the siege
exactly so um yeah it's it's not like a
fashion
statement it really it's an
inconvenience absolutely this i'm sure
this dog's great
but yeah if you've got to carry it come
on come on dog step your game up
i wish we could carry colonel editions
around new york oh that would be great
he would
lose his mind in a bad way he wouldn't
he would permanently scar him he'd be
like i've seen remember when you take
him out of the bags at airports and it's
just like
quaking yeah i had a question um
i will marry you again thank you that's
amazing i will need
another ring yeah and another owl more
importantly
um you love diners it turns out i love
american diamonds yes i mean i really
like diners but but i like them in a
kind of wow american
like this is what an american dining
room you like them from nostalgia
yeah well my because um as a child we
used to go to america in the summer and
america was this kind of magical place
where i think because i would only ever
go there when i didn't have school
and it was like you'd eat fruit loops
and dunkin donuts and diner food
sounds great it was amazing yeah i was
like america's a wonderful londoner we
have yet to go to a krispy cream and get
our free krispy kreme
if you're vaccinated you just get a free
krispy kreme every day
forever yeah so you don't get covered
but you do get type 2 diabetes
wow yeah we should do that um yeah
we've enjoyed being going to the diners
it's been really nice i've enjoyed being
here and i'm sorry that our enjoyment is
leading to you having a very truncated
episode with no news
however our venturing to new york will
has resulted in
lots of freestyle rap videos which are
going to be going up on the channel so
although there is not a freestyle wrap
in this episode there will be freestyle
raps that are on the channel every
wednesday
now from now forever there will never be
another pandemic that stops me from
rapping on stage
that's great yeah my brother keeps
saying these dispiriting things like
you know just because we've had a
pandemic doesn't make the chances of
there being another pandemic any slimmer
and we're like shut up and get back in
your room you boring
buzz joy buzz buzzjoy buzz kill killjoy
killjoy buzzjoint yes buzz lightyear
murderer
in getting lost i am getting lost which
you can't do in new york because it's a
grid system
as john mullaney says lost in home alone
2 lost in new york
it's a great sister [ __ ] where
you went lexington and
57th where do you want to go second and
55th
there's two across two down i feel like
a new yorker already
it's weird that there's first avenue
second avenue third avenue
lexington avenue fifth avenue i think i
don't think that's a fourth avenue
and with that fun fact that is the end
of the episode we do apologize for the
shortened nature of it
as the actor said to the bishop which if
you don't know is a very uh
common way of making a joke in the uk
you say something a little bit of
vaguely sexual and you go was the actor
said to the bishop
because actors and bishops apparently
had lots of sex with each other i'd
never really understood that
and now perfectly explained right next
week we will be back it will be a news
based
episode however it may also be short
because
of commitments to entertaining people in
stages around the country
uh but uh thank you very much for
listening do suggest new words for that
thing that alice came up with earlier
that's really hard to describe and
therefore
clearly needs a word for it it's not
original to think moist is a gross word
that's not a cool new thing you've come
up with it's like getting your [ __ ]
mustache tattoo on your index finger the
first person who did that was genuinely
absolutely brilliant iconoclastic but if
you do it now
that's not that cool yeah wait 20 years
it'll be ironic
yeah but also in 20 years there'll be
loads of sad 45 year olds going
oh my finger has a mustache on pleasure
talking to you thank you for listening
from me and her goodbye